(quirky music)
- No, I don't want it.
- Oh I don't want it.
- Peanut butter is a savory thing,
Thai people know about that.
- How do you? What is wrong with you?
- What's wrong with you?
- How fun is that?
- Am I pregnant?
Like, I'm so enjoying this.
- It's salty and sweet.
- It's sour and vinegary, it's gross.
- I like how crisp it is.
I also like that my mind cannot
figure out what I'm eating.
- The pickle's really tart.
- Pickle and peanut butter
are both very strong flavors,
so they fight each other so hard for the
dominant flavor in your mouth.
- I love hot Cheetos,
and I love pudding, but--
- I don't like 'em together.
- Yeah.
- Chili pudding is a
thing, chili and chocolate.
- Yes, chili and chocolate's so good.
- It's like a spicy sweet garbage smell.
- Oh that's nice.
- It's not terrible, oh
god it's weird though.
- It's like sweet on the outside,
and then crunchy and spicy in the middle.
- If marijuana didn't exist,
this snack could never come to be.
- Huh? Oh that's mayo.
- What is that white? No!
- What monster created this?
- It looks like something you
see on the side of the beach.
- Oh it smells (beep) weird!
It smells (beep) weird!
- Oh-ho.
- No, this is not good.
- It's so salty!
- I'm so sad. right now.
- It tastes like potato
salad but with a banana.
- It's almost like I'm swallowing glue.
- Slimy.
- Slimy nasty.
- Tastes like I ate a moldy crayon.
- You know, it's 'cause the
textures are so similar,
at some point it's like, "Is
it banana, is it mayonnaise,
"is it a nightmare, is
this even happening?"
- This one's a stoner ran out of cereal,
and was like, "What,
what's the difference?"
- The goldfish look like
they're in their natural habitat
for the first time actually.
- It's like a salty cheese.
- It's weird.
- This is the first food where like
the only taste I can describe is funny.
- My mouth is super dry now.
- I don't think I like goldfish like this
better than them by themselves.
(gasps)
- Smells like Hershey's Kisses.
- It does but then I'm
very terrified about
the underneath part mixed with it.
- That's weird.
- That's amazing.
- Feel like the pizza's screaming like,
"Taste me, taste me!"
- Well now I don't like it,
but half of me still likes it.
- This is awesome.
- The marinara sauce kills it for me.
- The Nutella sticks to
the roof of your mouth,
making the cheese stick
to the roof of your mouth,
so you're stuck with just
the bread on the bottom.
- You've got Nutella all over you.
- That's a woman's dream.
(quirky music)